just for kicks let's imagine someone
spinning a flaming tennis ball attached
to some type of a string or chain that
they're spinning it above their head
like this and let's say they're spinning
it at a constant speed
we've already described situations like
this maybe not with as much drama as
this one but we can visualize the
velocity vectors at different points for
the ball
so at this point let's say the velocity
vector will look like this the linear
velocity vector just to be super clear
so the linear velocity vector might look
something like that and it's going to
have magnitude v the magnitude of the
velocity vector you could also view as
its linear speed
now a few moments later what is the ball
going to be doing
well a few moments later the ball might
be let's say right over here we don't
want to lose the drama it's still
flaming we're assuming it's still
attached it's still attached to our
chain
right over here
but what would its velocity vector be
well we're assuming it has a constant
speed a constant linear speed so the
magnitude is going to be the same but
now it's going to be the direction is
going to be tangential to the circular
path at that point so our direction has
changed
now one way to think about this change
in direction of velocity it's a little
bit counterintuitive at first because
when we first think about acceleration
we tend to think in terms of change in
the magnitude of velocity but changing
keeping the magnitude the same but
changing the direction still involves an
acceleration
and at first it's a little
counter-intuitive the direction of that
acceleration but if i were to take this
second velocity vector and if i were to
shift it over here
and if i were to start it at the exact
same point
it would look something like it would
look something like this
it would look something like this
and actually let me do it in a slightly
different color so it's a little bit
more visible
so it would look something
like this this and this are they have
the same length and they're parallel so
they are the same vector and so in some
amount of time if you want to go from
this velocity vector and actually this
should be a little bit longer this
should look this should look like this
it should have the same magnitude as
this one
so it should look like this
so if in some amount of time this and
this should have the same magnitude if
in some amount of time you go from this
velocity vector to this velocity vector
your net change in velocity is going
radially inward this right over here is
your net change
this right over here is your net change
in velocity and so in other videos we
talk about this notion of centripetal
acceleration in order to keep something
going in this uniform circular motion in
order to keep changing the direction of
our velocity vector you are accelerating
it inward radially inward centripetal
acceleration inward acceleration and so
at all points in time you have an inward
acceleration which we denote the
magnitude we usually say is a with a c
subscript for centripetal sometimes
you'll see an a with an r subscript for
radial but in this context we will use
centripetal
now one question that you might have
been wondering this whole time that we
talked about centripetal acceleration is
newton's first law might be nagging you
newton's first law tells us that the
velocity of an object both its magnitude
and its direction will not change unless
there is some net force acting on the
object and we clearly see here that the
direction of our velocity vector is
changing so newton's first law tells us
that there must be some net force acting
on it and that net force is going to be
acting in the same direction as our
acceleration and so what we're going to
do here is introduce an idea of
centripetal force
so the centripetal force if it's
accelerating the object inwards in the
centripetal i guess you say in the
inward direction so we have a
centripetal
force that is causing
with that is causing our centripetal
acceleration f sub c right here we can
view that as the magnitude of our
centripetal force and the way that they
would be connected is come straight out
of newton's second law this isn't some
type of new different type of force this
is the same type of forces that we talk
about throughout physics we know that
our the magnitude of our centripetal
force is going to be equal to the mass
of our object times the magnitude of our
centripetal acceleration
you could if you want you could put
vectors on top of this you could say
something like this
and we know but we know the direction of
these of the centripetal force and the
centripetal acceleration it is inward
now what inward means the exact arrow is
going to be different at different
points but for any position for the ball
we know at least conceptually what
inward is going to be
so this is just to appreciate the idea
centripetal acceleration in classical
mechanics isn't just going to show up
out of nowhere newton's first law tells
us that if something is being
accelerated there must be a net force
acting on it and if it's being net if
it's if it's being accelerated inward in
in the centripetal direction i guess you
could say
then the force must also be acting
inward and they would just be related by
f equals m a which we learn from
newton's second law
and to appreciate the intuition for this
just remember the last time that you
were spinning or rotating a flaming
tennis ball attached to a chain above
your head in order to do that in order
to keep the ball spinning and not just
going and veering off in a straight line
you have to keep pulling you have to
keep pulling inward on your chain so
that the flaming tennis ball doesn't go
hit a wall and set things on to fire and
so what you are providing is that
centripetal force to keep that flaming
tennis ball in its uniform circular
motion